[Music]
i i signed up to
mid journey this weekend the ai oh yeah
um and
that's like dolly right it's like dolly
yeah yeah yeah it's a really good one
yeah it's better yeah it's way better
dude really yeah it's [ __ ] sick we
can make that thing but look so i try
to make moose getting hit by car images
what i got instead were these like
beautiful renditions of things i i did
like road kill what what came back was
way more demonic it was definitely on a
list
yeah no we're searching no no you know
who's on a list are all the [ __ ]
weirdos in there so
on mid journey
if if you're using the freeware version
you're in a massive group chat oh on
discord yeah yeah yeah i'm in that too
yeah but you see what everyone's putting
in there yeah yeah yeah the amount of
dudes putting cute anime girls away yeah
bruh yeah
and and when you pay for an account wait
why
and
there's like a feed you can go like a
community feed i like tapped into it for
a second last night it was all just
girls i'm like okay
yeah i'm out of here
i'm out of here [ __ ] that's because
here's the thing man that's so just
it's like
i mean i guess it's not that funny but
it's just like the guy who made this
just the years of
technological innovation
and you know the ingenuity required to
create an ai
to create images of anything for you and
dudes are just like porn yep
boobs four massive
uh jugs
milky jugs mama gaga sucky on the jugs
enter
is this your dolly
input history or goddamn sure we should
try that one see yeah i mean i can do it
real quick
i can just go on discord
[Music]
yeah so what is this this took a few
rounds but this is moose
it was supposed to like i had to put
moose in like it used to be so specific
i put moose
flying in air
car in background
and this was the closest of the images
that like represented
you can get way more specific than that
though i was trying to like get our save
the date designed and talking to this
guy and he was like yeah we could try
and use mid journey and so we're like
and the the the prompt he was using was
so [ __ ] specific
like literally 30 words describing
exactly to a t the style
what he wanted
and
i mean it listened when you do the style
like there's like i mean garrett was
doing such like specific like
photographers like styles yeah like blah
blah blah photography yeah
black and white portraiture that's like
beautiful looking real that's great yeah
the [ __ ] that garrett has been making is
[ __ ] creepy i've been a part of this
beta for a while yeah but that was the
first time that i was like oh there's a
commercial use for this just for me i
would pay someone like this designer i
was like can you maybe work on this with
me and he was like yeah sure let me use
mid journey for this first step and i
was like oh this is where this lands in
the creative process you're also firing
that person
yeah exactly cool you're fired
sorry this thing is like being
[ __ ] dude
[ __ ]
sorry
okay while he's doing that type in boobs
nipple
um two big jugs no because then what's
gonna come back are like jugs of water
so you gotta get more specific yeah a
lot of people like are doing like
found footage as a style okay so found
footage of two jugs mama
then after put
actually i mean breasts i'm just gonna
put nice nipples okay
you can't do anything that would bring
an explicit result oh
what did you say before
uh
milky jugs
uh
you've been blocked for accessing mid
journeys happens on repeated serious tos
violations will be unblocked in four
minutes ah what no actually so you just
got me [ __ ] violated dude wait just
for typing it
you didn't even send it no no i i tried
to make the bot do it
prudes spock created some
horrific stuff like scary like this
[Music]
you gotta bank these and save them for
the next time you guys do shrooms
together yeah
yeah and then pull that out and be hey
garrett remember this
screenshot this right now and anytime
one of your friends is tripping send
them this what is he what is he typing
for that
i don't know he's doing those long
things like he knows like all the ins
and outs now like that's so funny that
game yeah guys played mid journey for
three hours it's addicting man i know
yeah i got a
this is pretty lazy on my part i just
i didn't try to affect it too much
so this is what when i put in roadkill
that's pretty good that's an album cover
for sure yeah
so this is just me [ __ ] around
photoshop this image is like dumb as
[ __ ] but
that's cool i like how'd you make that i
like took what's in that gold ring like
i took the gold ring and the contents of
it
out and then like the one below it i was
like [ __ ] with like the ripple effect
and stuff and i was just i don't know
did you start with an image from mid
journey
yeah and then i just started cutting it
up in photoshop and then just made it
into this yeah
yeah
it's pretty sick
pretty sick
yeah i like this watercolor look and
then cash has taken this picture of me
that looked like a painting so that's
kind of blended the two
wait so oh they're already charging for
it
oh yeah
but it's a discord bot
yeah so like i can message it right now
so let's see if my four minutes well
it's weird that it's still on discord
why not just make it like stand-alone
thing if they're charging for it is it
still beta bot is built into discord
yeah
i know but
that's what i'm saying it's kind of
weird
like their engine like there could be
any front end for that it doesn't have
to be discord
damn so it's kind of weird that it still
uses this one but they ended this one
with i don't know whatever the whole
thing is but then they ended it with wes
anderson colors
yeah that's it makes it like
oh it's just
what the things you can put in i'll be
unblocked in
six minutes
what
circumventing this filter to violate our
rules may result in your access being
revoked
so this works in the same way that
uh just like language processing ai
works
i i searched road kill
it just crawls every single image
ever posted online
got it
and learns from it's like how it's
tagged
so that's what it's doing when you're
putting in prompts yeah it's just
finding it's just combining all the
images
yeah that makes sense i just tried to
put imagine fast car
and i'm banned for six minutes so
i'll check back i mean yeah what are you
doing putting that filth in there my bad
fast car
[Music]
imagine perfect mail on go-kart
[Music]
perfect mail
going 75 in a shifter car yeah
and then it just shows
not me
obviously
you